eight months ago i made a promise if i
ever hit 10
000 subscribers this becomes a minecraft
let's play channel
no more books and like a fool i double
down on that promise
when i hit 10 000 subscribers this
channel becomes
minecraft channel in my hubris i
believed that time would evade me
i believed i could prolong the issue for
eternity
what what could i do you know i i
struggled i built a channel based on my
true passion of
reading and and now it had to end
because nobody would let go of a
throwaway joke in a video from eight
months ago now i have nothing all i
could do was drink and bemoan
the inevitable march of time i did what
i had to do
for my reputation and for you
ladies and gentlemen welcome to
minecraft uh let's play number one this
is so much fun
excuse me can you be quiet oh i hit him
okay he's running
that's okay i have to kill him now
killing people speedrun i'm gonna drown
i'm gonna drown dream not found
speedrun uh i'm just gonna start killing
everything i see
i don't need books i don't need to talk
about books to make content what a fun
game i
there's a treasure chest and there's
just a bunch of potatoes i need don't
know how to eat
food that might be a problem this is fun
this is going
really well i can i can figure this out
i can
i can figure something out as much as i
love clinging to a thin comedy bit and
making clickbait thumbnails
i have to follow my heart
i will be making new booktube content i
learned my lesson
50k subs i will dress as wit
you